travail et du verre en fusion une
première pour ces élèves de l'école
darbo ville de rambouillet sous la
direction de vincent il découvre le
métier de souffleur de verre en
laboratoire une expérience proposée par
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin dans le cadre de la fête de la
science est basse après et du coup sa
taille de gaulle après après sa soeur
ses conseillers de quartiers difficiles
mais cette semaine nouvelle est ce qu a
accueilli près de 800 élèves dans ses
locaux un événement pour apprendre la
science autrement la science c'est quand
même assez abstrait et là par quelques
petits ateliers on arrive un petit peu
plus précisément à dire un scientifique
ça fait ça et ça sert à quoi ça sert à
des choses quand même très précises
parfois ça suscite des vocations avec le
latmos les enfants découvrent aussi
l'atmosphère
de quoi est elle constituée comment
l'analyser c'est l'objet de cette
expérience les jeunes apprennent
l'utilisation des ballons au service de
la science comme on est un laboratoire
qui a un long passé de l'exploration
spatiale avec des fusées des ballons on
essaie de leur expliquer finalement
l'intérêt et la physique qui a autour
des ballons l'intérêt pour l'atmosphère
pour la prévision météo que dont on est
bien au courant de désinformation que
qu'on a tous les jours chaque enfant a
pu écrire sur une carte postale accroché
un ballon gonflé d'hélium
ils ont été ensuite libérés dans le ciel
certains arriveront peut-être en
allemagne où jusqu'en suède dimanche 16
octobre le vs qu sera ouvert au public
les grands curieux pourront eux aussi
tester ces ateliers